denn ich muss sagen ich freue mich heute
ganz besonders es gibt menschen wir
spielen jetzt schon darüber dass man die
sind einfach großartig und super und
xavier im boden verschwinden aber weil
es so schön war und ich mich so froh
dass das auch anderen auffällt wollen
wir noch mal das hier zeigen
ist es wieder zeit für den begehrten
preis im deutschen fernsehen
der deutsche bundesbesitz befreit
[Applaus]
weiß
wir haben wieder ein liebling gefunden
ja schlimmer weise bei btv sorry sie
hört auf den namen celine behringer und
geht in ihrem job als vip expertin so
dermaßen auf dass selbst gute laune
dabei bekomme obwohl es bei bild tv
stattfindet team jünger hier ist auf
jeden fall die krasseste vip geschichte
des tages beim webradio als
mitschuldigen soffin warum nur mit einem
heißen typen rum machen wenn man zwei
heiße typen kann und bitte aber hey es
ist als wäre ich dafür quasi und lasst
sie doch machen die frau emine listiger
on demand süß oder new york
verliebt verlobt verheiratet knutschi
knutscht du du bist es du bist der
einzige grund wirklich gesagt haben ja
warum nicht
verhaftet wegen sexy ich meine hier
herrscherin über lack und löcher
ich finde es ein bisschen komisch
papperlapapp und jetzt wm billion euro
völlig gar
mein touch itac ist weg oder was
ehrlicherweise könnte ich jetzt einfach
mal die klappe halten bei
ich muss euch wirklich verrate als
junges mädchen habe ich tatsächlich
immer davon geträumt mal so ne button
wenn man drauf drückt sollen wir dir
hier den ein bisschen daneben habe ich
schon bekommen und jetzt halt die nummer
noch also swr es wäre ein traum wenn ich
da wirklich auf diesem sofa sitzen
dürfte aber wir erfüllen hier ein ganz
anderes träumten vor deinem schließt du
hierher das ist sowieso der traum
schlechthin und mega traum ist ja immer
sonnig nur erotik erotik macht uns allen
spaß egal ob weiblein oder männlein gut
und natürlich natürlich werden auch und
ich habe hier liefern und so wunderbare
nummer eins hier im lg prada heute und
zwar ist das model joanna aus brasilien
und sie sehen was hat die hier mit
familie smits zu tun machen wir gleich
eins nach anderen weil ihr geht's auf
jeden fall richtig ab wenn sie sich
selbst anschaut
hier sehen wir sie auch nochmal luana
serbien ist als 28 jahre jung
erfolgreiches model aus brasilien wie
schon gesagt und hat immerhin geschafft
fünf millionen dollar schon zu scheffeln
also ist einiges nicht unbekannt in
brasilien ja und jetzt lösen sich auch
warum wir diese frauen niemals vergessen
werden
diese frau ist
autos excel was bedeutet das pferd sieht
total drauf ab wenn die hier so ein auto
sieht hier ich zeigt sich nochmal ist
dann bei ihr alles vorbei und spaß im
bett sein auto sexuell das ist
tatsächlich nur der name dieser ist sexy
sexualität
luana steht voll drauf wenn sie sich
selbst im spiegel sie das reicht sie
braucht keinen man sie braucht keine
frau sie braucht wirklich einfach nur
ihr eigenes spiegelbild
und dann ist ja oder ja von anfang an
wichtig einfach mal so sagen und so
stehen lassen und der zusammenhang hier
zu dieser sehr sehr berühmten familie
die wir alle kennen zudem mit
dass auch sie ja liebe anders machen als
normalos sage ich jetzt einfach mal bei
denen ist das glück nicht autos
sexualität sondern offene ehe das
praktizieren die beiden hier schon seit
vielen vielen jahren und haben
tatsächlich auch ihre tochter willow
damit angesteckt sie liebt es auch
einfach mehrere menschen zu lieben und
ganz ehrlich daumen hoch dafür jeder
soll lieben wie er mag und wir alle
haben auf jeden fall hier an dieser
stelle sexuell wieder richtig was
gelernt würde ich sagen ja und wir
bleiben erotisch natürlich mit
die muss doch gar nicht sagen
und sie kommt hier nicht ins radar wegen
einer besonderen sexualität wir wissen
sie steht auf jüngere männer und muss
man auch wenn man so aussieht nein sie
hat es hier geschafft weil
weil sie einfach 63 jahre alt ist und
einfach solche fotos jetzt gemacht hat
für das us magazin parade hat sind diese
bilder hier raus gehauen und ihr
schönheitsgeheimnis das hat sie diesen
magazin auch verraten das ist nämlich
einfach stretch meditations- workouts
sie kann also quasi ihren kopf mit ihren
zehn berühren das mit 63 und ohne sich
auf zu werfen wissen wir auch bescheid
ob diese dame das auch kann das habe ich
mich erst gefragt aber dann frage ich
mich gar nicht mehr weil hier
wo bist du denn ist dass kim kardashian
nein das ist lisa ag kennen einige von
ihnen ganz sicher war war sehr präsent
im tv war bei germany's next topmodel
dabei hat immerhin auf platz zwölf
geschafft na ja und jetzt macht ihr
sehr sehr viele fans frohe möchte ich in
bern auf instagram hat so wirklich eine
riesen karriere jetzt am start mit neuem
namen lisa del piero heißt sie da jetzt
ist fitness influenza rinn hat 800
36.000 vorne war es wirklich eine menge
holz ist da kann man dann sehr sehr gut
von leben naja und eine top tipp
patricia kai volle aufmerksamkeit jetzt
hier bitten ist dieser
stoß mit diesem ding hier drauf und dann
kriegt man guckt mal hier sieht man auch
wahnsinnig gut den vergleich von so
einem kleinen süßen pose und
riesengroßen co wie wär's denn mal die
stücke mir die ihr habt diese sehr auch
nicht gerade bequem aber der pass wir
gleich einen größeren po auch nicht mehr
drauf ist wohl leben also wenn wir denen
noch vergrößern da hast du dich unrecht
aber trotzdem das solltet ihr vielleicht
mal probieren ich wäre dafür dass
service stunden damit den minister
gestellt
und ein klima in europa ja das wäre doch
google mal alle froh